you cannot negotiate and you cannot talk
to a terrorist organization this is this
is unrealistic there's a state fighting
against a terrorist organization
fighting against terrorism and you
expect us to sit and talk with it with
terrorists well they were they were
former allies of the Americans and the
British that's disappearing if US and
British or any other country around the
world ally with the terrorists so we
hope that they do have a
misunderstanding of who they are
otherwise we don't want to consider that
any country who ally with us are the
allies or terrorists I just hope that
that's not true I wish that they'll
change their policies that's that's the
only hope I can have for them indeed
would you consider negotiating with the
Syrian regime Syrian regime is
responsible indeed from all these
atrocities going through entire Syria
Syrian regime is the one who is
responsible for those four million
refugees who live in Turkey Syrian
regime is responsible for all those
terror and terrorists including - and
PKK gaining ground in that country so
why should we sit and talk with such a
regime a regime which have already
killed millions of his own students so
that's a no that's a no okay so how are
we going to get out of this mess which
and and I'd like to talk about the phone
call the key phone call that changed it
all on October the 6th the Turkish view
is that they were implicitly given
degree
like the go-ahead by President Trump now
ever since that phone call the Americans
seem to be saying that's not what
happened and they're very much blaming
the Turkish for provoking a humanitarian
crisis redrawing the map of the Middle
East and creating an unprecedented
mayhem in the area of course not of
course not there's not just not as such
a case indeed we are not redrawing any
map we are if we talk about the
humanitarian case indeed it's us Turkey
who provides the humanitarian assistance
to all so we are there for humanitarian
reasons the turkey should have been
accused of bombing civilian convoy how
is that providing humanitarian that's
totally a lie that's not true at all
just think about the operations that was
going through that that happened in
muscle do you remember that operation I
was there do you remember how that
operation was held and do you remember
the civilians that were killed
throughout that operation so you were
with us I guess during the you phrase
shield operation and all the branch
operation so it was like a surgical
operation indeed differentiating the
civilians from the terrorists so we did
sorry to interrupt but that's impossible
that's impossible to do with terrorists
indeed in that area remember not only
PKK terrorists but - terrorists as well
but we have differentiated and that's
exactly what we haven't been doing right
now indeed believe me it's the area the
targeted area for us the safe zone the
buffer zone for Turkey clearing up from
the terrorists is just it's it's a
matter of a couple of days of operation
nothing more than that
the reason it takes more is basically
for our humanitarian reasons we are
extremely careful extremely curved
for civilian casualties for kids woman
and elderly extremely curved what what
explanation is there then for the
bombing of the civilian convoy because
though colleagues from British channels
filmed and talked to these I know that
information indeed I just look into that
but I don't know that that information
okay president Edwin says has written
this morning in the Wall Street Journal
talking about developing his own plan
for North East Syria and he's basically
said join our efforts to all his critics
or begin admitting refugees is that a
threat can you explain it's never a
threat indeed so what I realize want is
that turkey is great and long live
Turkey when it comes to keeping the
refugees hosting the refugees in Turkey
Turkey has to receive all the refugees
from Syrian side and Turkey has to keep
all the refugees from basically going
them through the European side when it
comes to hosting them in Europe all of a
sudden turkey becomes a bad guy well
what we are what we have the reality is
that for this four million refugees and
another three million possible ones in
Eid Lipsyte is a potential refugee issue
for Europe as well so European countries
have to stand up and have to take the
responsibility
standing by turkey for helping refugees
for solving refugee issues for solving
the Syrian issue politically and also
for sharing the burden in Turkey so if
the
does not happen Turkey cannot host four
million refugees and not and cannot
receive another three million refugees
from the Syrian side for forever so this
is affect sooner or later
these refugees would like to go to the
European site because turkey is not a
destination country for forever so
Turkey Europe is a destination geography
as well so if they want to go to Europe
we can prevent for for it for a certain
time what we have done so far what we
cannot do it again forever so this is
another threat indeed this is a reality
that president Erdogan is just trying to
show to our allies can we go on to
another subject you've been criticized
by almost everybody even America about
for sparking and humanitarian crisis but
there's another humanitarian crisis
again I have to I guess I have to
correct the consulate the humanitarian
credit there is already a humanitarian
crisis in which in the region in Syria
there is a humanitarian crisis going on
for eight years there is a humanitarian
crisis for four million refugees living
in Turkey
so just naming it as humanitarian crisis
like our operation as a humanitarian
crisis from 10,000 miles away is easy
sitting back having your coffee and
calling it a humanitarian crisis is easy
but what we are talking about is that we
are facing two main issues refugees
issue we are trying to solve because
they would like to get back and live in
their own country they were not able to
they all fled to Turkey from the nearby
areas of our southern borders which
right now totally controlled by PKK
terrorists so by clearing them up from
that area they'll be able to get back to
their own homeland
be able to live in their homeland and
second there is a threat security threat
for our own students for our own borders
and we are trying to clear up that
threat true clearing up the terrorists
both - and PKK terrorists so
humanitarian crisis is the existing one
so we are trying to reverse the
humanitarian crisis not create a
humanitarian crisis okay can I ask about
your particular allies now that the
people the Syrian National Army the that
you're backing there have been a lot of
criticisms about the makeup of that
group that their affiliations and links
to al-qaeda
for instance possible criminals and
convictions can I just finish the
question yeah they have been they have
been videoed executing civilians with
hands tied behind their backs they are
being accused of killing the Kurdish
leader
Heffron caliph what do you say about you
have been we have been very very careful
with the NGOs or with all the Syrian
people and the Syrian National Army by
every individual and very careful in
terms of man being any type of ties with
in radical groups including al-qaeda
because we are in fight with al-qaeda as
well with - so never ever
we will let such a tide happen in that
grouping we ourselves are fighting
against - in al-qaeda within our own
borders and in Syria as well so for
those videos we have been investigating
them as well so we will not allow any of
those groups to have any type of
atrocities and for the videos we have
been checking into whether that's a
relative or
something some kind of some kind of
makeup so we have been investigating
into it and will never ever tolerate
today and the killing of the Kurdish
female leader I mean that would be all
of these would be called war crimes what
we have been fighting with is against
the terrorist group
we do not shouldn't kill any civilian
our army will never ever harm any of the
civilians unless he or she is part of
the terrorist group belonging to either
PKK or - or any other terrorist group in
that sense and fighting against us
otherwise we will not harm any any
civilians so she would be considered a
legitimate target I don't have
information about the specific case
indeed can we talk about if she's
involved with the terrorist organization
of course yes and if she's in fight
against us
in the area within that group so that
that might be considered part of which
that will not be considered as a
civilian issue but I'll check into that
specific case the Isis prisoners
everyone is concerned about what's
happening to all the Islamic state
prisoners that are in Northeast Syria
the two issues for the - prisoners we
are trying to control take control over
the prisons that are within our
operation area operation spring Aryan
piss spring area so that's our first
goal to get those prisons under control
the rest is easy
the second we like the one happened
yesterday indeed if they are allowed to
go by PKK terrorists that's exactly what
happened yesterday
and that did happen during our operation
you freights shield two years back
indeed they did let them go to fight
against us
PKK did let them did let the -
terrorists go fight against us so we did
fight and as I said before we did
destroy it indeed more than 4,000 -
terrorists then and now we will recover
them
I mean arrest them find and arrest them
no matter where they go no matter where
they hide as long as they are within our
borders of the safe zone so we are not
we are not gonna let them go can I ask
about members is the Turkish army
military prepared to take on Assad's men
/ manage are you going to fight them we
hope that's not gonna happen
but again we are determined to get the
control over member Cheney men which was
an area again we were there we were
there not to control over the area in it
we were there to provide a safe heaven
for the local people in it local people
are the Arabs over there
so those are obscene right now live in
Turkey as refugees again our goal is to
let those locals get back to their own
homes the SDF so-called forces are again
like why like the YPG they are all parts
of PKK they have changed the demography
over there by force forcing the local
people out so right now what we want is
let those locals get back to their own
homes and live in their own homes
that's the reason we are there and the
promise that was given to Turkey by us
was that all those terrorists were gonna
leave the area within 90 days so it's
been more than one year they have not
left yet so we are there and we would
like to take control over the tip part
even if that means fighting the Syrian
regime forces let those locals get back
to their own homes because those people
were afraid of the Syrian regime as well
and that would mean taking on the Syrian
regime forces you I hope that's not
gonna be the case we have been talking
with Russia as well our ministers and
our institutions are in constant talk
with all the parts again we hope that
that's not gonna be the issue but we are
determined to take the control of the
area so yes yes the buffer zone this is
that this is the area if you remember
this is something that our president
showed as shown in the United Nations
this is the buffer zone indeed
throughout our borders so most of the
refugees living in Turkey Arabs Kurds
and Turkmen as Christians Muslims mostly
came from this area so they will be
getting back to their own homes and
basically restoring the demography over
there
the second is that will be a buffer zone
for Turkey for the security so that that
will be cleared up from the terrorist
groups including - and can you explain
are you extending it all the way up to
the iraqi border and this is where we
are right now
this is televi --it and this is
wrestling this is where we are but again
this is a buffer zone this is throughout
this area this is here is in which it's
not an extension it is this is something
that we have we have been talking about
30 miles from the border site
so this is exactly the part that we have
been talking since the beginning India
so what we want from the international
arena is some kind of help to create
such an environment that refugees would
like to get back to that area rather
than basically being against turkey
operation and so the operation that we
have been handling is a humanitarian
operation that's the reason we have
called the operation as piece spring do
you think you got the green light from
American bring peace to the region
indeed do you think you got the green
light from America though because they
seem to be saying one thing in public
and another thing in private to you well
we did not ask for permission from
anybody indeed because the conditions
that we are in somehow forced us start
this operation indeed so we cannot we
have tried to make our case for the
entire world but we were not able to so
we have somehow almost outcry letting
everybody know that this operation will
start unless a solution to both cases
the refugee issue and the PKK terrorism
and - there's those threats at worst
turkey unless those two issues a result
Turkey will start its own operation so
we have made it very clear and that's
what we did because we were not able to
get any help from any part of the world
so right now I guess it's alright to ask
for those countries to stand by with
turkey rather than basically standing by
with a terrorist organization perhaps by
marching into Syria you have opened the
doors to Bashar al-assad taking
reclaiming more parts of Syria because
now
they teamed up with your old enemy the
SDF and that'sthat's the main that's the
main reason that we want to be in min
which indeed because for regime to take
over women which is not a solution for
these refugees because that said himself
was the main reason they fled out from
Syria because there were many atrocities
over there so that is the main reason
that we want to be there and will not
let anybody to ally with any terrorist
organization so we will be there until
Turkish borders are safe from terrorist
threats and again we'll be there until
we find a solution to refugee to keep it
safe there that must mean keeping the
regime out from your point of view
hosted safe a safe zone will be our own
Turkey turkeys control and you will man
that and keep it safe or until a
solution is formed found and formed in
Syria so we do respect Syrian territory
we do respect integrity of the Syrian
borders as Turkey
we are for the unity of the Syria and
Syrian borders indeed so nobody should
look for any other goals or objectives
as far as this operation is concerned
and we make our objectives very clear so
we are not going to be there for forever
because it's a huge cost for Turkey as
well so this for the area security but
maybe years you might be data hopefully
it's not gonna be for years that's the
reason I said they hopefully this
constitutional committee will start
working as soon as possible so that
solution will be provided over there and
all the refugees will get back Syria and
just getting back to our own borders